this is the day ramsey shot we're glad
you're with us America thanks for
hanging out with us you and twelve
million of your closest friends we
appreciate you sticking around thanks
for being here the phone number if you
want to talk is triple eight eight two
five five two two five as you guys know
we don't have guests on the show you are
the guest you callers call in we talk to
you about your life and your money but
occasionally I'll make an exception and
for a couple segments here I'm going to
make an exception again some of you are
new to this Dave Ramsey game and some of
you've been hanging out with us for
twenty five years and most of you know
that we broadcast our show from
Brentwood Tennessee which is Nashville
Tennessee for all practical purposes a
suburb of Nashville and so having been
in this market for a very very long time
a lot of our friends in the business are
like super famous country artists like
mega Rockstar famous type people and we
get to know them and hang out with them
and find out that they're like real
people and they're cool and all that
kind of stuff and so sometimes they drop
by to say hi and that's the case today
if you've ever heard of a group called
Lady Antebellum they've earned six
platinum singles they were dubbed ACM
and CMA vocal group of the year three
years in a row and of course need you
now that the song of songs of theirs
it's kind of made their lives good and
and a whole bunch of us that listen and
Hilary Scott is the prettiest version of
Lady Antebellum and prettiest member
anyway without a doubt the guys wouldn't
mind me saying that that's for sure so
Hilary's gonna drop by and talk to us
for a little bit and she's written songs
for Blake Shelton and Sarah Evans number
one hit a little bit stronger and former
MTSU student and we've kind of watched
her grow up a little bit right when Lady
a was coming out and got moving and so
forth and she got famous well then
everybody started going now wait a
minute we know that yeah that girl was
over there at the church and that girl
was over there at that and but she's
absolutely absolutely an incredible
artist and obviously world-class and
lady a has done that and so she has a
new album coming back so coming out has
just come out and is doing extremely
well so we got to have lunch a while ago
talk about that and I asked her to stop
in and hang out here in the studio a
little bit late
you guys hear a little bit of behind
behind the scenes on the music business
a little bit welcome Hillary thank you
I'm so honored to be here I appreciate
it well it's so good to have you so good
to have you and tell us this new album
is love remains and it was released when
it came out on July 29th
okay so just been a little little bit
over a month yeah and it is really our
it's me and my family so it's Hillary
Scott and the Scott family and we just
really wanted to as a family use the
gifts that God has given us through
music and and talk about our family and
and our faith and that's what these
songs are and so it's a Christian songs
a lot of them but country yes it's a
faith-based country album so it's
showing up on both charts yes and and
that's been such an exciting part of of
it all to Ricky Skaggs produced it so
we're getting some of the bluegrass
we're getting the country elements well
not to mention he's a musical genius and
playing all over this oh yeah he's
laying he can't talk he just he can't
talk without talking about Jesus yes
he's so fun I love Rick Ricky and Sharon
are good folks very cool so yeah that
that's pretty cool when you do you come
from a musical family I mean you come by
this honest
thank you both my parents moved from
their hometowns my dad's from South
Carolina and my mom's from Texas and
they moved here for music my mom always
tells the story she moved here to sing
on the Grand Ole Opry and she's done
that many a time on her own and we got
to do that as a family just the same
week that the record came out and so it
has been she's had an incredible career
she sang a duet with Reba McEntire and
called does he love you that won a
Grammy oh yeah I always tell the story
in the little house I grew up in we
didn't have a mantel or any real
bookshelves because it was not very big
and so my mom is Grammy sat on the
microwave that works works on your dad
your dad's right his first big hit you
were telling us at lunch yeah he
co-wrote a song for LeAnn Rimes that was
on her first record when she was just a
little girl mm-hmm and he that I've told
you the story at lunch that that helped
us get into our new house and it started
my college fund for me so it was a big
blessing for our family back in the day
you know I was talking to one of the old
country guys one of the ones that's
another generation back or so and they
were telling me that they remember your
mom with her voice to do its to do work
and that she was pregnant with you doing
a studio session so you would go around
pregnant with me and do demos and even
once I was born she would take me I have
so many people just randomly at
different music functions come up to me
and say you were three years old in the
studio with your mom while she's saying
a demo and that was it I mean that was
in it's so funny how history repeats
itself because I'm doing the same thing
with my daughter she just turned three
and she goes everywhere with me
why not I mean that's that's the nature
of the business and the beautiful thing
about country music is it's a safe
environment and you know the kids can be
around that and if they're behaving
anyway and so so love remains in the big
single has gone ding ding I will yes
it's kicking where are you on the charts
with it I think we are just crept into
the top five on Christian radio this
week it's sitting at number four and a
lot of people have watched the video and
and have bought the single and it's been
overwhelming you know this song
it's the most personal song I've ever
written one it's because it really
stemmed from a really hard time that my
husband and I walked through almost a
year ago actually two the day we lost
our second pregnancy we miscarried our
second baby and and I in those you know
weeks following really found myself in
prayer on my knees a lot just you know
asking the Lord like a lot of why like
why does this have to happen to me to
anybody but at the end of it all just
choosing to trust and know that his will
is is what's best and so you know I I
don't say that lightly I think that's a
hard
that's a hard for words to really fully
believe with your whole being just that
you know things like this have to happen
but but watching and hearing the stories
of so many who whose hearts are being
touched by this song so much beauty has
already come from
really hard thing and so it's um it's
been a blessing mm-hmm Hillary Scott
with Lady Antebellum is joining us for a
couple segments she's gonna be one of
the speakers at our business boutique
event that's coming up in Nashville that
Christy Wright does you know the
equipping women to make money doing what
they love yeah I'm that they're gonna
let me speak at this one
so about Hillary will be there and be
interviewed and I'm gonna do a little
devotional time for us and so forth and
probably do this song you know you might
hear that a couple songs you might
happen that we might get a music person
to play a song that could happen so
she's part of our business boutique
lineup and you need to check that out at
business boutique calm it is November
4th and 5th it is not yet sold out it is
going to sell out early you guys I'm
looking at the reports coming in by my
email I get a update on all the live
event reports and this thing is it's
going to zoom zoom and so on this event
is pretty incredible right Rachel Cruise
will be speaking Christine Caine if
you've not heard Christine oh my
goodness Donald Miller Amy Porterfield
Nicole water Walters Jess Conway will be
there and of course Hillary Scott with
Lady Antebellum I'll be there don't
Miller and I are the two token guys I
think of this thing so it's gonna be a
lot of fun though ladies the you need to
come it's a two-day event it'll change
your life
about running a business or starting a
business business boutique calm you can
get tickets there or you can call
triple-a 22-piece back with another
segment with Hillary Scott from Lady
Antebellum in just a minute the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys Rachel Cruz here
hope you enjoyed that video from the
Dave Ramsey show if you want to watch
another great video check out my video
three things you should consider renting
right over here or click the link in the
description below
you